in Nashville beto aurora told immigrants
that our country was founded on white
supremacy slavery and oppression other
than that were awesome this country was
founded on white supremacy and every
single institution and structure that we
have in our country still reflects the
legacy of slavery and segregation and
Jim Crow and suppression even in our
democracy so right from the womb were
all racists it's the new original sin
according to Slenderman as his
popularity shrinks faster than his own
spine Beto's efforts to sow division
only expands
he's like a bitter divorce husband
trashing the ex-wife to his poor kids if
he can't be happy no one can used to be
that politicians running for office had
a number of tools at their disposal not
bado
he is the tool talk about a blunt object
it's only function is to create victims
out of brown and black Americans so that
they might look to him
the great white scarecrow as their
savior but now it's true competence is
exposed as a farce for so long as
failures were propped up by a bottomless
spousal income then assisted by a Vanity
Fair cover bestowed on him by a pale
liberals enamored that he looked just
like them
he was as white patronizing slick and
elitist as the magazine all that was
missing with a smelly cologne ads he's
so white Wonderbread could sue him for
plagiarism
now he's reduced to playing for radical
scraps dancing to the fight songs of
undergrads and safe spaces a wind-up toy
for brats and Che Guevara shirts he'll
say anything so now we're all racist by
birth he shouts like a hopeless lonely
slob at last call desperate for a phone
number I'd say go home you're drunk but
he might Drive I wonder if I was not
mean enough taken more made more mein
Greg who thought this guy had any
potential he I mean sois well looks like
Churchill compared to this guy indeed
and he was better-looking and so ah well
it's not in it anymore I'll give him
that
so his hit he's gonna fight racial
inequality in this country starting with
a Vanity Fair cover and then his
follow-up was a stet story in
New Yorker which basically no one reads
and just tells everybody else that they
read it can better bounce back yes I
love that so you can't practice identity
politics if you have no personal
identity and he doesn't you can see the
thought bubble over his head what am I
gonna do when I'm done with this maybe
I'll become a dentist maybe I'll learn
how to use a loom and and make some
alpaca throws and sell them on Etsy is a
nobody and he is a nothing
he's the Etsy candidate so one I came up
with a phrase I think you'll like
I call it woke shrinkage it's like if
you continue to smear everybody as
unwove and oppressors you just narrow
your party until no one's around you I
call that woke shrinkage I think that's
pretty clever I thought you were saying
that you thought it was sort of this
political expedience that he was saying
this then he was trying to in fact you
know rejuvenate his candidacy which is
what you were saying that worker piece
was about right yeah well but but but
let me just say I don't think there's
any debate that what he said is true oh
yes there is
yeah this is not our country was not
found' was founded on white supremacy oh
I would disagree
well I wouldn't because I would say
founders reserved the franchise the
voting franchise for land owning white
males I think that was it in other words
Bagan and Dana couldn't vote I know I
could was it founded on sexes and do you
own land I don't think you are sexism -
well yeah I mean in other words Jesse to
say this is the historical fact as
palling I'm just saying that's the fact
Barack Obama didn't even say that about
our I'm just telling most beautiful
inspiring things about this nation's
founding he didn't get anywhere close to
what you said or bado or or first it's
gonna run for president I'm not this
country never would say something
anybody who knows American history would
say okay so that's a reality the
question I don't think anybody agrees
with that one we wait you know how can
you disagree with the idea that America
that the founding father said you got to
be a land owning white male - just
because something happened at a time
doesn't define the founding what are you
talking about
during the founding doesn't mean we were
founded on slavery in white supremacy I
just think that's a fact of our of our
American being and we couldn't define
the founding of course it doesn't know
what does not let me just finish this
point I think the left sees this and I
think bata workers reflecting that and
says let's fix it let's do something
about my subjects anything I think
that's right like you refuses to even
say oh yeah you know what that's part of
the original I said it is I acknowledge
that there was slavery in this country I
acknowledge that women or black
Americans didn't have certain rights but
one we fought and 600,000 people died
radical said every institution in this
country is racist
well the military the media just
everything is racist one you don't agree
with that are you kidding the military
is one as our leading exaggeration of
diversity but every single institution
in this country is racist no but Jesse
even the military military heads am I
gonna have to separate your tuition
we can't ever talk about race anymore
can we I think better O'Rourke is the
only one who doesn't know that his
campaign is over
yes he's like Bruce Willis in the sixth
sense yes don't I don't want to spoil it
[Laughter]
you didn't see it I think I don't
remember you don't remember the ending
of the success it's kind of the whole
point of the movie is the ending I think
do you remember the ending of the
Titanic yes the ship doesn't make it
through
oh yeah Josh about a shark anyway I
think if it keeps going is going to ruin
his future opportunities to run for
other political office ooh that's a good
little piece of advice from Dana Perino
so it in the sixth sense what happens is
no I can't do that because there are
people watching I've never seen them go
come on
nice that's an old movie you can do it
alright he was dead all along oh hey I
see dead people falling father we tried
so hard with you